alors c'était important de le lire dans
l'intégralité parce que c'est vrai que
dès la 10eme phrase emmanuel macron a
donc dit que le lien entre l'église et
l'état étaient abîmées alors c'est ce
qui est un peu provocateur c'est ce qui
a fait réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
les uns et les autres
donc moi du coup j'ai pris la volonté de
lire tous de l'intervention et j'ai
remarqué qu'il y avait des choses
positives et des choses moins positive
pour moi qui suit
pour la laïcité donc c'est vrai que il a
des mots ou des phrases qui sont un
petit peu gênantes comme ce lien abîmé
pour moi le lien entre l'église et
l'état n'est pas abîmée puisqu'il y a eu
séparation des églises et de l'état
qu'ils disent que les catholiques se
sentent un petit peu abandonné
oserais-je dire où ça je peux l'entendre
cette phrase la gelée très très mal
comprise ensuite il défend quand même la
loi de 1905 donc ça c'est très bien et
il dit d'ailleurs que tous les lois de
la république doivent être au dessus de
toutes les lois est solide